hi welcome to the meeting of the
planning policy committee
all right welcome to the meeting of the
planning policy committee members when I
invite you to speak please ensure you
have one of the microphones in front of
you before speaking
as microphones are needed for the
hearing Loop and for the audio recording
these are all switched on ready for you
to speak so you do not need to adjust
them
please make sure that the microphone is
directly in front of you before speaking
members voting will be done on a show of
hand in line with the Constitution
I will ask for a show of hands four and
then against recommendations
those abstaining from voting will be
noted by officers
agenda item one apologies for absence
none have been received
agenda item two non-members attending we
have councilor Ian Ward councilor Andrew
cross
Council Simon Wooten councilor sparing
and councilor Stanley and councilor
Angelina Marriott
I'm sorry I couldn't say councilor Crips
thank you
and Council of light
thank you
a gender item three minutes of the
meeting held on the 23rd of June 2021
members are the minutes agreed
on the bed now yes
okay I was there as well and I'd agree
them thank you
agenda item four to receive Declarations
of Interest members are there any
Declarations of Interest
councilor steptime
cancer Newport
okay councilor alumley
it's a member of Essex County Council
thank you
yes uh chairman Essex County Council the
monitoring officers advisement
chairman that is in response to uh item
eight of the
um yeah okay thank you in that case
chairman on that advice
County councilor
okay thank you
chairman chairman to confirm Council
Steptoe Council on the Council of Hawaii
and Council in Newport has declared an
interest to automate thank you
right agenda item number five local plan
evidence base open space study 2022
members Daniel kudler will present the
officer's report
all right
okay you can hear me excellent hi good
evening everyone
um those who haven't met me before my
name is Dan cuddler I'm a senior
strategic Planner on the planning policy
team
um so the open space study is an
important part of evidence-based for the
new local plan it helps identify areas
in the district where there may be a
deficiency and provision of either open
space in general or specific categories
of open space such as play areas or
natural Green Space Etc the study is an
update of the earlier 2009 study and it
provides a comprehensive audit and
Analysis of the district's open space
provision in terms of quantity quality
and accessibility using nationally
recognized Benchmark standards for these
GIS mapping software was used to assess
quantity and accessibility using
standards that assess the amount of open
space per 1000 population for quantity
and for accessibility the study looks at
walking distance of Open Spaces from
communities allowing for the
identification of areas which are poorly
catered for using the national
benchmarks for accessibility for example
where for a children's play Space
um you know the The Benchmark will be
600 meters or a 12 to 13 minute walk or
for a natural Green Space that would be
at 920 meters or a 20 minute walk for
the quality Assessments in the study
these are based on 165 site visits to
the vast majority of the district's Open
Spaces undertaken by the team using the
green flag criteria relating to
accessibility security cleanliness
Maintenance and
Facilities and amenities
um this information will be used in the
new local plan to ensure any potential
development sites in these communities
contributes new provision
in terms of the findings beginning with
quantity the study identified 707
hectares of open space which equates to
just over eight hectares per 1000 people
in the districts uh 43 of this was a
recreation or outdoor sports facilities
for example football crickets
um whilst a further 36 was natural and
semi-natural open space
in terms of geographical distribution
there is an uneven picture as shown in
map one on the committee paper the
majority of open space is concentrated
in the western half of the district
um where on one hand you have high
concentration of population and on the
other hand you have the upper roach
Valley and places like Hockley woods and
Cherry Orchard Country Park eastern half
is more sparsely populated contains more
open Farmland along with the mod land in
terms of wards roach self contain the
most open space
whilst hawkwell East had the least
having no space within its tightly drawn
boundaries although a number of sites
just outside
in terms of the recommended Benchmark
standards for different types of open
space per thousand people the district's
performance varies so exceeds standards
and provision for things such as
Recreation and Outdoor Sports
um 3.48 hectares per 10 per thousand
against a benchmark nationally of 1.6
and things like natural and semi-natural
green space 2.92 per thousand compared
to a benchmark of 1.8 however provision
falls short of the standard for things
such as amenity Green Space 0.29
compared to 0.6 play spaces 0.06
compared to 0.25 and the allotments 0.13
compared to differing national standards
arriving 0.21 or 0.3 the district's
population is set to increase by 12.5 to
2040.
um this would mean less open space per
thousand residents if no further space
is provided
um So currently it's eight it's just
over eight hectares per thousand people
um by 2040 this would be 7.19 hectares
per thousand people if if um if nothing
was done to increase provision
so a further 8.88.3 hectares of ocean
space would need to be provided in order
to give a similar level of provision
new development housings traditionally
been a key enabler of new open space
with around 85 hectares delivered in
this way since 2009 through sort of
housing schemes and a further 76
hectares currently in the pipeline
so those are things which are you know
due to be built out at some point
in terms of the quality assessment 45 of
the sites audited were rated excellent
or very good although 29 or it says to
be fair or poor the better scoring sites
had a good range of facilities were in
generally good condition or accessible
well signed and felt safe uh I'd refer
you to Table Three in the committee
paper for more details along with
appendix C of the accompanying reports
which is
um a link fee but very comprehensive set
of um
accounts of the um the the site visits
for for each of those 165 sites
so those will be eventually you know put
on the website for you know for the for
deep diving in terms of accessibility
the analysis showed the majority
populated areas are within walking
distance of an open space we're
virtually all over urban areas and the
majority of villages catered for however
there are some notable exceptions for
example Southeast holbridge and areas of
Rochford close to yourself in road and
ashington road
and these areas actually you know within
a reasonable walking distance you you
know you
someone wouldn't encounter an open space
in terms of rural communities there is
also an issue as well places such as
South randbridge outlying areas of
canuden and pagle stream again no
designated Open Spaces within walking
distance
um and when you consider whether a
community as I access to Open Spaces
which are publicly accessible so not
private sports facilities and things
like that or considering you know places
which have access walking distance to
more than one open space the gaps become
more notable uh details settlement by
settlement analysis is available in the
report
um so the report sets out ways to tackle
deficiencies in provision which should
be considered alongside the local plan
and is as it is progressed ensuring that
any site allocations and site-specific
policies help plug the gaps in access to
open space for both existing and new
communities
so this could include designating new
areas of open space
repurposing existing open space for
alternative uses and providing the
provision elsewhere in a more
appropriate place to ensure there's no
net loss or using existing spaces
and adapting them to provide a greater
diversity of amenities
so that's the overview and happy to take
any questions or you know come back to
you in more detail offline if that's
more useful thanks
thank you Daniel members do we have any
questions
counselor Steptoe
thank you chairman uh just a query
commentary there that wrote South is got
the largest amount which I'm very
pleased to say because it's my board
um is that partly because of Cherry
Orchard yes
okay and the other question was that I
I'm not sure if I've missed it in the
paper but do you include Open Spaces
that are owned by parishes I'm thinking
of for example Barling Wildlife Park uh
yes yes so barley Wildlife Park is
included in there
um what is not necessarily included are
things like open agricultural land that
might have public rights of way running
through it where obviously people can
walk along the footpaths and you know
enjoy the openness but it's not
necessarily A an accessible open space
and similarly certain local Wildlife
sites or things such as Wallace Island
where again the public has access but
it's you know it's the point of it is to
be a you know a Wildlife Reserve route
NSI a special scientific interest rather
than
um you know a public open space so it's
the so so it's fair to say that you know
the full picture of provision within the
district you need to consider that now
network of Rights of way alongside
um you know the the 707 hectare so you
do have a little bit of additional
okay Jim if I can come back
um you mentioned Wallace Island there I
wasn't clear is Wallace Island included
or not it's not no no okay
okay thank you
I'm saying other questions
councilor Hawaii
chairman just a few points which
questions as well because I've got I
have concerns about the report and what
it misses out and where it leaves us
with the
recommendation which is printed twice in
here but the one I'm looking at is on
page 5.18
which I think is quite Lucid I think
we've been called out before in the past
with our local plan where we don't
we leave things
to further stages in the process rather
than trying to nail them down early and
it said I mean it's it's recommended
that any future spatial strategy site
selection and an education process for
me to the new local plans considers the
findings presented in this study
um to consider how new developers might
help address any existing deficits it
doesn't really
there's no bite there is there it's
quite loose and I'd like to understand
that but before
and on that place you when I'm sorry
with the idea of asking for it to be
reconsidered and put back to the
committee to reconsider a few other
points I'm trying to make now as well
um
one of which is about equality on
diversity implications I think we've got
into quite a lot about accessibility of
the site but there's nothing about
accessibility for for the disabled at
all I'm aware I think we're doing
something in property Woods at the
moment to address this issue but I think
this report should have mentioned that
it's a it's a big thing at the moment
there's no mention of
really of toilet facilities I know hold
with Recreation ground is lucky it's got
a toilet facility there's a public
toilet by the river I'm not sure where
about other areas but perhaps we should
be considering this if we're if we're
opening
if we're trying to get more land I know
hope just been quite lucky and getting
I think of six by two hectares with the
new development
um perhaps we should be thinking about
toilet facilities because there are some
people who cannot get out because they
need to be able to know there's a toilet
near where they're going
um
and I think that that should have been
considered the report along with the the
ability of those less able-bodied people
to use these spaces
um I got concerned about them some of
the privately owned sites which you've
said are publicly accessible but
holbridge Sports a social club is not
publicly accessible
they have Gates on it you can go and
watch football there if you pay you can
go and play football there so I'm not
sure that it
I'm not sure
if we're excluding Farmers Fields while
we're including hold Bridge folks and
social club I'm aware it's a sports
ground but it's not publicly accessible
and I think the sales probably for the
Rugby Club Tennis Club as well probably
um King George is playing field
obviously that's public publicly
accessible but I've got concerns around
how that works as well I think there's
the contradiction I found which I think
you've slightly mentioned is that
holbridge comes up with really good open
space figures but then it says is not
very accessible because it's quite a
long walk for some people there I'm not
sure if that contradicts or if that's
accurate I don't don't know on that one
and one of the other points is with the
big thing about what I've read out is
the recommendation is about how new
developments might help address any
existing deficits now we talk about
quantity and we're talking about quality
obviously
new developments tend to be the public
open space so this has been a bug
burrito of calcium Sperry when he used
to share this committee are usually
funded within this Council by a private
management company which is paid for
solely by the residents of that new
estate so in holbridge for instance High
elms
the houses on high Elms which is the new
estate parrot David Wilson homes will be
paying
for
the maintenance of the open space on
that area including the play areas
and I who do not live unable go and use
it so I think this is an error I think
it's the bird estate in Rayleigh I'm not
looking to council confirmation which
council is very she always used to
mention which is felt no one know who
owns it anymore and it's okay you'll
probably fall back to the council to be
maintained at some point so I think that
he's in a mission in the report we're
not really talking about that and I
think if we're going to send it if we
assign it needs to be addressed by new
developments we need to address how this
is going to work and if our current
model is an acceptable way of working
okay Council hi thank you I'll take um
some advice actually if I'm a
um we ask we ask some questions and
there weren't any uh we're being asked
to note the report yeah
I'm just asking for some advice
I could ask
is it appropriate to note the report and
make additional recommendations to be
fed back into the process
and clarify some of the questions that
Council Hoy has so if we can just hear
from the office of us but I I took them
mainly as observations right no they
were questions
okay no thank you councilor Hoy and you
know I appreciate the points you're
making and I think you know they they
are they are valid ones to be honest so
this is you know this is a piece of
evidence base for the new local plan
um so you know we we can make
recommendations through you know broad
recommendations for things like you know
new development should help
you know plug the gaps in provision and
accessibility and you know that's that's
something that um you know local plan
evidence base would typically do so you
know if it was found that you know
there's a glaring great big hole in you
know a certain community and
there were certain promoted sites coming
forward there which you know which
perhaps had potential for you know
delivering housing then absolutely you
know part of that future site-specific
policy links that allocation perhaps
should involve some sort of contribution
towards open space I appreciate that you
know we are you know at this stage being
fairly
um you know woolly in terms of that
because we are waiting for you know
additional pieces of evidence for the
local plan things like infrastructure
delivery plan
um absolutely it's at your point
regarding accessibility
um and you know talking about you know I
mean obviously accessibility is refer to
extensively in the report but that's
more about generally how someone might
walk or or drive to a site but you're
absolutely right that you know we need
to consider you know how disabled people
might access a site and in that respect
probably the majority of Open Spaces you
know would would perhaps not necessarily
be up to scratch
um we can certainly you know we can
certainly look at you know adding some
adding some caveats to reflect that and
and you know
aspirations perhaps for for um you know
if you're doing better
um
the point around privately owned sites
is is a valid one
um you know within the reports well
within the appendix to the reports which
um which you know isn't there today we
do talk where we have identified
um you know private site manager you
know site management company
um
but you're correct that the report does
not necessarily go into details about
you know the delivery mechanism and the
fact that you know a large amount of
future provision coming through
development would would be um you know
brought forward in that way and
maintained in that way
and um yes you're right I mean I think
the issue with holbridge is that you
know there is there is fairly goods and
it's and it's it's done an award by Ward
basis
um so
there is you know there is fairly good
overall provision
um you're you know you're obviously
reference things like the sports and
social club which is a private site
um we we inherited
um a methodology from the 2009 study uh
and and um and the data sets which
looked at you know football size at a
whole as a whole rugby sites as a whole
Cricket sites for example and and I do
appreciate that it doesn't within that
you know delineate between public and
private and you know we do there are
caveats within the document that talk
about this so yeah I can I'm very happy
to come back with a you know with a
fuller answer you know privately if
that's useful
um
Mr Goodman's asked to
um
yeah thank you chair um I think the
thing that I was just going to add
around the identification of sites
really was that in the allocations plan
we already have uh quite a large number
of protected open spaces so the starting
point really for assessing sites has
been those protected open spaces so that
includes public and private sites
because although they don't have a
public right of access always those
private Sports sites for example are
still worth safeguarding and so you know
from an allocations perspective they're
still protected because if a planning
application came in we'd want to see
them uh their loss offset or we'd want
to see their loss avoided and so in that
sense
they make up a part of the overall
provision I think you know what we what
we'd accept is that there is a
difference between a site that's got
full Public Access and no private no
Public Access and there are sites that
are somewhere in the middle but in terms
of the sites that have been assessed and
the the underlying data then certainly
we have a good idea for every site
whether it's in public ownership private
ownership and so in that sense we have
the underlying data to be able to to say
you know well this is what it looks like
just including public sites that's what
it looks like just including private
sites it does get slightly messy because
what you'll find inevitably is that you
have private sites that aren't available
for for sports but they might have
public rights of way going through the
middle of them and there's perhaps a
sense that they are public although
they're not so in that on that specific
issue I think the the private sites are
in there for a very important reasoning
that they make up part of that provision
although you know I think we accept that
there is a distinction between public
and private sites I think just in terms
of the purpose of the study as well I
think what I would say is that the
purpose to tell you this sense is in at
this stage it's really just evidence to
inform a future decision and so in that
sense there's no uh it's not policy
there's no sense at the moment that you
know if we were to um
yeah look at the the findings now that
they necessarily
um bind the committee into into looking
at anything in a certain way in the
future
um and so in that sense there's
um you know that there may be a need
obviously to prepare an addendum or
something to this kind of study in the
future to pick up on those kinds of
issues as well so it is just evidence
and I think just to clarify and I think
I'm right in saying this but the
recommendation is set out at
10.1 what's unfortunately kind of worded
at 3.36 is a more passive recommendation
in the sense of what we are suggesting
the study would be used for but that's
not actually the recommendation that
we're putting forward to the committee
so hope that clarifies if there's any
question that hasn't been answered more
than happy to come back yeah if I may
come back chairman um
a question and then I and perhaps to
build on what um Daniel Goodman said the
question is how so for places such as
holy sports and social club the Tennis
Club and the other one which I'm on the
wrong page for
how these are privately owned clubs
which have scored highly in quality how
much that have they skewed the quality
assessment
if they were removed would the quality
go down significantly because I noticed
they were around 90 odd percent whereas
the average was 92 72 I'm sorry yeah I
mean I'd say that's always the that's
always the issue when you aggregate
things in tables is that they start to
have obviously average things out I mean
what I would say is that the underlying
data obviously allows for all of the
site assessment quality assessment
um for every site to be unpicked and so
we can we can package up summary tables
in you know many different ways in the
sense by emitting X and emitting y I'd
say it probably depends for example if
you've got a ward with lots of private
sports clubs then that's going to be
skewed more that you might find their
Awards with next to no private SKU
private Sports Club so they're not
skewed as much
there will be an element of skewing if
you were to look at it in a public
versus private sense and just because
there's obviously quite a lot of private
sports clubs in there there are also
obviously lots of public Recreation
grounds okay if I just might come back
then around what David Woodman said my
concern is that this is an Evidence an
Evidence document so what's in it will
be used as evidence to effectively
eventually go into the local plan which
will would then be policy
um uh Daniel Cooper mentioned about an
addendum is it possible to add an
addendum raising my concerns on the
issues I've raised which seems to be and
Daniel coedler seemed to have been
reasonable agreement with most of them
as to be in a good point
yeah
I mean everything that you've suggested
around that the accessibility in a
slightly different sense to how we've
used that word
um and picking those things up I think
I'm fairly confident we can we can add
as an addendum so
um I mean
subject to obviously any other questions
or observations that might be made by
the committee I think we would be fairly
comfortable to to you know commit to
doing you know a follow-up addendum that
addresses some of those issues I mean in
a sense probably neither of us are
qualified to do a very very robust
accessibility assessment in terms of you
know qualities Etc but what we can
certainly look to do is is do
um something that addresses that thing
in-house and if we need to if there's a
compelling case to then obviously
consider
um consider doing that you know in a
more specialist sense so we can we can
have a look at those options I think
there's a compelling case to do so but
that we can
um I'm not sure whether that can be done
in the addendum or or they saw a chance
to pick that up further along the line I
don't know
indeed I think I'll describe that as a
work in progress that part
and that will be picked up
is that fair
ly addendum Council Newport
thank you chairman
um
it's not going to come as any surprise
to Daniel but um or Dan how
uh how disappointed I was with the
quality of the report
um
in the appendix I think you'll find that
the page numbers don't match up the maps
are poor quality and the table layouts
Dreadful
um on page 5.10
item uh 3.21 local Green Space
assessment
um I think you were discussing of both
public and private play Space
um
can you tell me why that ready Town
sports and social club has been omitted
from that list because I can't see it in
there
in terms of a local Green Space
recommendation do you mean yeah
um I will have to I mean I'll have to go
back to our um our uh our spreadsheet
which looks you know at the the
methodology against the uh a set you
know a range of national criteria so
yeah happy to happy to pick that up and
and come back to you on that
chairman
um
given the uh the quality of the report
I'd like to recommend that this report
goes back to
um planning policy for further work and
hopefully I've got a second there on
there hold on a second
hey advice just take advice on that
please Angela is that appropriate
so chairman there's a motion on the
floor for
for the report to go back to planning
policy
um to be reconsidered
um
however this report is merely for noting
and the officers have taken
um the observations and the concerns of
councilor Hoy and councilor Newport into
consideration the motion is on floor
it's been seconded by councilor Hoy and
I um members will have to take a vote on
that okay
councilor Steptoe was asking to speak
before that motion was placed thank you
chairman
um I was picking up on the point of the
new Estates where they have these Open
Spaces I have had communication from a
number of residents on one particular
state where it's they're paid having to
pay something like 300 pound a year
towards maintenance
and they're questioning whether those
Open Spaces are public open spaces now
is it conceivable that they could be
closed off as they've managed by a
private company and
linked to the that particular state
secondly with regards to
sports Fields
the development that is currently going
on at Saturn with the South End United
training ground that is now well
underway and that is quite a substantial
side would that should that be also be
included
thank you councilor step two just
picking up on the south end United Point
first I I would suggest probably not
because it's clearly it's for formal
professional or semi-professional
standard sports facilities that's not to
say it's not important but I think there
probably is a distinction in the in the
methodology around
the types of facilities that might be
available at a kind of lower level and
those facilities once they are
established I think we can consider the
case to protect them but but at the
moment I think we would struggle
probably to do a quality assessment of
them because they don't yet exist
and would probably struggle to do an
accessibility assessment of them
likewise so
um I mean I mean I think we'd be more
than happy to consider to consider the
case to do that
there's probably a distinction in my
mind and I'm happy to to happy to kind
of have my mind have my mind kind of
challenged but between that kind of
facility and the type that's looked at
in the in the report but but clearly we
can we can take a look at that
um
could you kindly remind me of your first
question sorry on regards to new Estates
sure where they're they're paying quite
substantial management fees uh 300 odd
pound a year in one particular case and
residents are saying well hang on a sec
we're paying for this why is it it's not
necessarily publicly open
yes and I think that that's a fair point
I think from the purpose of the the
report what we've looked at is Open
Spaces that that require protecting
through the plan and I would include in
that types of open space that are built
on new developments that are privately
managed because it by being safeguarded
for the local plan as open space clearly
that's another way of protecting against
their loss for that for their
um value for the community clearly some
management companies will attempt to
prevent public access to those sites
others less so
um so that so it is a slightly hard
picture in terms of the actual
long-term safeguarding of that land I
mean in the planning process the loss of
that land is highly highly likely to be
resisted because it will be protected
for in the planning consent Etc I think
what's a slightly different issue and
one that's probably not possible to pick
up in the report is around the fate of
management companies after a long period
of time and I think that's something
we've touched on upon today so
management companies that exist for an
amount of time and then disappear and
people aren't clear what then the fate
of that land is that's a challenge
but not one that can easily be picked up
in this kind of planning assessment I'd
say it's probably a management
management issue but those
open those privately managed Open Spaces
are still worthy of being included in
the report because clearly they make up
part of that provision just important I
think as we picked up in other
conversations that they're clearly
delineated as privately managed as
opposed to public and if we need to do
some analysis around public open space
compared to private open space and I
think we can do that to avoid it skewing
the picture when it comes to to looking
at provision
if that answers your question thank you
just to comment on South United yes I do
accept the fact that it is a big hole at
the moment with a great big bulldozer
sitting in the middle of it so I do
accept it it's not quite there yet
thank you yeah and I think just to
summarize I think what I'd say on that
point is if there is a case to consider
it in a future assessment I think we can
do that but it does it states us at the
moment does feel like slightly different
to the rest of the sites
thank you
good reminders of the wording of the
motion please Angela
chairman I think you'd have to turn to
council Newport thank you yes
sorry
counseling
chairman I would uh like to recommend to
the committee that this uh report is
sent back to planning policy for further
um work and since uh councilor Steptoe I
take it was speaking to that motion I'll
just add his little bit in there that
um there's obviously a lot of issues
that are unresolved that need to be
looked at before this report comes
forward to planning policy again please
could I propose an amendment
to include the wording to address the
issues that have been raised this
evening
yeah
okay okay
all the vote on the amendment
all in favor
thank you famous vote on the motion all
in favor
unanimous thank you
so chairman were you doing abstentions
and
was that unanimous goodbye
members agenda item six spatial options
regulation 18 consultation feedback
report
members Daniel kudler will present the
officer's report
thank you chairman uh I'm going to pick
out a few of the key headline findings
from the reports although I would stress
that the report itself contains a far
more in-depth analysis of a wide range
of issues and the appendix 3 within that
report summarizes and the response is
received on a question by question and
settlement by settlement basis all
individual responses can also be viewed
on the online platform
the consultation took place last year
between 28th of July and 21st of
September it was accompanied by a range
of publicity including physical mail out
series of pop-up events email newsletter
webinar and a range of social media
notices in total over 1500 unique
responses were received to the
consultation representing the views of
1814 respondents
this is where we were notified by the
respondent that you know they they were
representing a household of two or four
or so on
we received almost 7 000 unique
responses to the various questions set
out in the documents giving us a large
body of data to go through the vast
majority of responses were from
individuals I.E residents and businesses
in the district
although alongside that we had responses
from development Community
um from neighboring local authorities
and other statutory consultes for
example
um anglian water Essex County Council
people like that
one of the main questions the
consultation sought to ask was the
feedback on the space spatial strategy
options proposed I.E broadly what
patterns should development take how
should it be concentrated and where
should it be located
this particular question received 380
358 responses representing 419
individuals the open-ended nature of the
question meant many consultancies gave
more than one preference for an option
so we have sought to include this range
of opinion in the committee reports if I
could refer you to table 2 you'll see
the full range of preferences expressed
which include second preferences
alongside this a table 3 seeks to merge
these into more simplified preferences
as a quick reminder option one is to
prioritize development on Brownfield and
urban sites option two is a strategy
pursuing Urban extensions
option three is an approach
concentrating growth somewhere in the
district
well in the in um in three different
potential locations whilst options four
is an approach combining a number of the
above
on balance when considering the options
presented the preference was for a
concentrated grocer option I.E option
three although opinion on that was
closely split between 3A West of
Rayleigh and 3B north of South End
it is important to note that large
number of responses around 39 with other
options not presented within the
consultation this includes all views
which didn't fit neatly into one of the
spatial strategy options presented so
examples within that include response
who were against any form of development
whatsoever whatsoever
those who are in favor of an
infrastructure first approach where
development would not be permitted
without the appropriate infrastructure
being provided alongside it those who in
favor of a limited amount of development
in order to satisfy local needs and also
a range of neutral responses from
statutory Consultants such as Essex
County Council
most people will acknowledge the need
for a degree of housing however there
are strong views about the quantity
required as well as the types of housing
needed for example more affordable
housing or more appropriate housing for
the elderly for first-time buyers or for
young families
um it's also worth noting that option
one scored well
with a significant body of respondents
supporting the principled Brownfield
development
this option was also supported by many
who supported option three alongside the
idea of a new community
of the options presented in the
consultation individual respondents
favored option three and its ability to
deliver infrastructure required
um whilst the the development community
so
site promoters house builders developers
and agents were more likely to back
versions of option two which were seen
as a way of delivering housing and
infrastructure in a shorter time scale
um the next headline from the um from
the consultation was around
infrastructure first so infrastructure
was one of the most common prevailing
themes within the consultation
existing communities were concerned
about pressures and their new
development would bring to existing
infrastructure for example roads
Healthcare and education they were
strongly urged that new infrastructure
was adequately planned for where
required and full regard given to the
capacity of existing amenities to cope
with development impacts provision was
urged to be delivered in advance of or
alongside development rather than as an
afterthought
this contributed significantly to the
appeal of the concentrated growth option
presented in spatial strategy option
number three as this was deemed to give
the scale which which might provide the
the infrastructure required
and there was some perception in some
comments that schemes in the past had
not necessarily delivered what had been
promised and there was a desire to avoid
this again
um next theme was around Greenbelt so
the um the scale of promoted sites in
the consultation on Greenbelt Land was
emotive and raised concerns about over
development it raised questions about
whether key aspects of the vision for
example being the district being a green
and pleasant land were necessarily
compatible with the scale of housing
proposed there was particular support
for proposals within the consultation to
protect the upper roach Valley Coastal
protection belts and local green spaces
but that more should be done to protect
um Greenbelt Land as a whole
uh there was particular support for
protection of agricultural lands with
many notings value and providing country
with food security
and the next um you know final headline
I'd like to talk about today is around
climate change sustainability many
comments indicated a growing awareness
of climate change and concerns around
its effects an emphasis on
sustainability was a common theme within
responses and it was particularly
concerned about the district's low-lying
Coastal Coastal geography in many areas
um this fed into concern around the
scale and proposed locations of some
developments with concerns around the
environmental impact for example loss of
natural habitats heightened risk of
flooding and risk of building in car
dependency on potential new schemes
which might risk increasing air
pollution
mitigations and solutions which um which
were which responses backed included
more Brownfield development higher
Energy Efficiency standards
uh on-site Renewable Power Generation
electric vehicle charging infrastructure
better public transport and cycling
infrastructure
many residents felt the highest possible
standards needed to be sought in
development as a way of achieving
achieving Net Zero although there was
some challenge to this from the
development industry in terms of the
viability of doing so and whether theirs
need to go beyond the forthcoming
government future home standards
um I hope that was useful and
informative and appreciated his brief in
comparison with the scope of the
consultation which did cover everything
from
um the scope of design policies and the
future of the airport through to you
know views on how to best support High
streets and local economy
we'd be happy to take any questions or
alternatively you know come back in
Greater detail thank you very much
there's any questions
Council Steptoe yes thank you chairman
um I have a couple of quite big concerns
with this report and agreeing to the
recommendations uh first of all yes the
option of using Brownfield sites first I
think is a must
but we don't seem to have a definitive
list of what Brownfield sites we have
uh I'd like to see a definitive list of
that
one of the concerns I have about
Brownfield sites is does that include
things like in current industrial states
which there are one or two and the one
that swings to mind is the one in roarth
which Tech cleaning now is in the wrong
place because of the development around
it
will that could be considered a
Brownfield site but of course that then
needs to be replaced for employment so
where do we put that
the other main concern that I have is
with what is happening nationally
the national issues at the moment which
I'm sure everybody is fully aware of
there are figures and quotes on whether
we can use Greenbelt Land and how
Greenbelt Land is going to be protected
and this that and everything else is so
up in the air
I don't think
we fully understand what the
implications of those going to be and
therefore I would like to suggest that
we need to fully understand that before
we go further with this report
they're my feelings on that particular
issues
thank you councilor step two I think on
the point around Brownfield land I mean
we do publish a Brownfield register
we're currently working on an update to
that register that should be published
shortly so there is a list of Brownfield
sites
um
and there is information on the website
and elsewhere around how many albeit we
are doing an update that will obviously
be more accurate than that information
it currently is so I think in terms of
some of the sites you've indicated or
referred to I think you know any site
that's currently available for
development as far as we understand it
that meets the definition of Brownfield
so that's sites that are in for planning
or sites that have been identified in
planning documents or so for example raw
of industrial estate is allocated in the
allocations plan for housing you know it
has challenges in that it's in obviously
a multitude of ownerships as we know but
all those sites make up the Brownfield
register and obviously together that
will give a capacity for Brownfield land
that we know about that doesn't mean all
of those sites will definitely be
delivered but you know clearly it gives
us a good idea about the capacity so
that information does exist in in a
format in that register format
I think the point around
um the local plan and National policy I
think what I would say is that this
feedback report is very much summarizing
a consultation that has been so the
consultation happened and obviously this
is the feedback that we got from that
process so in noting the feedback report
essentially what I suppose what we are
asking the committee to do is to close
the door on that consultation we're not
asking necessarily the committee as part
of this item to pre-determine or to to
um to take anything in terms of the next
steps as a matter of detail we're asking
obviously to note the report and to take
on board what it says as we move forward
to the next stage of the local plan but
when we come back with more information
on the local plan those will be their
own decisions in their own right and it
will be for the committee to determine
what it wants to do with that
information at that stage so we're not
looking to predetermine any part of that
process moving forward but we would
obviously like to be able to publish the
feedback report because it closes the
door on that consultation that has
already been and therefore it provides a
a point in time you know basically an
account of that process which currently
doesn't exist and which we are obliged
to publish under under law so in that
sense that that's what the purpose of
the report is and
um hopefully you know not in not to to
kind of pre-judge the next stages so to
speak
about that chairman
um with regards to uh going back to the
Brownfield sites in industrial areas
if I would you mentioned we mentioned
rural it's an ideal one to explain if
that comes forward how do we Square the
circle in supplying further employment
land will that have to come from Green
Belt
and therefore creating further
Brownfield sites
so thank you Council stepped out I think
in terms of what the allocations plan
says admitting that it's a you know an
eight-year-old document now is that the
land that was allocated out of
michelin's farm was expected in some way
to compensate for that loss so in a kind
of macro economic sense
there has been a move in terms of land
allocations to to compensate for that
loss now what's obviously actually
happened is that land hasn't been lost
and that has come forward separately but
it isn't really possible in planning to
safeguard land for the occupants of an
existing piece of land so to speak all
we can really do is direct land to be
replaced elsewhere I mean as far as the
understand that we have is that there is
no at the moment there is not a
great need for more large-scale
employment land in the district and
that's because largely the needs being
met say airport Business Park and
michelin's farm but that's not to say
that that Council in the future may
determine as part of the local new local
plan that it does want to provide new
commercial employment land and that it
does want that to be you know in the
Rayleigh area to compensate for any
potential future loss of Rover
industrial estate at the moment we you
know we can't compel the private Market
to bring forward or industrial estate
for housing you know and so in that
sense there's no concrete certainty over
whether it will or won't be lost
um but at the moment you know all I can
really say on that is that you know it's
lost was compensated for a point in time
albeit compensated for in a macro sense
it's not been compensated for in in the
sense of people on Royal industrial
estate are guaranteed to get a unit
somewhere else because that's not really
something planning can planning can
account for
briefly um
you know we're also in the process and
moment of commissioning and economic
development needs assessment
um so you know we're updating our
evidence base to understand you know
what what is the picture in the district
in terms of demand for employment space
demand for different types of employment
space you know what's you know how has
you know how have occupied demands and
then you know the nature of Industry
change since the last time we did this
in 2017 you know what types of um you
know employment spaces now in demand and
you know what is the market doing to to
respond to that and where are they you
know gaps in the market so we hope you
know we hope um you know within
a number of months to have an updated
picture on that and that will help
inform you know the um the allocations
um you know picture going forward in the
in the new local plan
before I take counselor Hawaii's excuse
me question I wonder if councilor Ward
portfolio holder perhaps would come in
and comment on the latter part of
council's Step toes question about the
national situation
okay
uh well as far as I can understand with
the national situation
we have to be aware that looking at
recent newspaper report as far as Castle
point is concerned it would seem as if
councils have got to get on with their
local plan and get it out and get moving
on it I think it's an important factor
that we all have to recognize that it's
important that we look at what is
relevant as far as our planning is
concerned and the evidence documents
that need to be presented but until we
have that evidence in and we've looked
at everything we can't choose any
preferred options at all we have to look
at all the evidence and where it points
and of course we're going to be coming
on to the transportation assessment
which is going to be very very important
and in conjunction with Essex County
Council and I'm to see we have four
representatives from Essex County
Council who will be our partners
in looking at this assessment
and I think it's going to be important
on them to ensure that they are Partners
in this thank you
thank you Council
councilor Hawaii I think you were first
yep absolutely
um I do agree with councilor 60 points
in particularly on the national area I
agree with Council of world as well we
have to have the evidence in place
before we can go move forward but I
think it's very very important the
evidence base is complete and correct as
it possibly can be
um
this item six is about the consultation
feedback report
um
what's underlying it I can't recall make
because it's about what people have said
I've got one thing I want to make clear
in a minute but the first point I want
to make is that
we have 141 others which haven't really
been analyzed at all but it suggested
that a lot of them could have been for
do nothing but I'm not sure there's no
figures there there's no nothing about
what that meant
my my
proposal is that we or my motion is to
send this document back so the planning
Policy Department and ask for additional
analysis to be done on the other so we
we are making a decision on a
complete document with all the facts
behind it rather than make a decision
where we don't really know what the 141
means enough I think it's important
these we understand what we're making
decisions on I think that's very
important you might see mine and it's
just one line in there but it's 141
responses
um
so that's my motion I don't know if I've
got a second before that oh second and
just talking to that I should have
racist before I did the motion really
but I hope chairman gives me leeway on
page 22 we've got transport and
connectivity and we have South in
Borough Council yet again
proposing that there's an opportunity
for an outer strategic Highway route
between a130 radiant holbridge which I
obviously fundamentally oppose
yeah
just explained page 22 of paper so I
suppose a thank you and it's yeah sorry
I should have said that and it's um
summary of consultation responses
four point table three
and it's about two pages on paper into
that
so it talks about improvements to a127
but further down it's better this fabled
new East-West route or west east route
and I just want to make sure that I am
fundamentally opposed to that
right there were two recommendations
the paper
I understand I'm just explaining the two
recommendations in the paper first part
was to note
and the other one is about consideration
are you suggesting we don't note
the whole back to Planet the whole thing
back to for additional analysis work
on the other 141 which is by far the
majority of the responses
so within appendix a um paragraph 5.8
um no well yeah 5.10 sorry there is a
the following paragraphs to explain what
the other responses are and go into a
bit of detail
we should be taking a vote on that
that's not for the officer to uh take
part in that to make home
right we have motion on the table
seconded all those in favor
against
motion is carried five to one in favor
thank you
gender item seven
statement of community involvement
members Daniel Goodman will present the
officer's report
thank you chairman
so this uh this item relates to the
statement of community involvement 2022
update
so the council has an adopted statement
of community involvement it's a document
that sets out how it will engage
communities and other interested parties
in the planning process so it goes uh it
goes into detail around plan making so
around the local plan it also goes into
detail around planning applications and
also enforcement
the council adopted its statement
Community involvement in 2016 but we are
obliged by law to review the document
every five years
that review took place last year and it
found that there were a small number of
issues with the current adopted version
including reference to ways in which the
public can can make representations such
as via facts that are no longer possible
it also
um some text was also a rad added around
how the council would
accommodate for the covid-19 pandemic
which is obviously topical at the time
because we were Consulting in summer
autumn 2021 when there were restrictions
in place those amendments are perhaps
now not required however nevertheless
they still provide an account of that
provision at that point in time
uh the council also received quite a
comprehensive response from Essex County
Council and that was suggesting some
further minor amendments uh that um we
are suggesting are taken forward are
they considered to to add Clarity rather
than fundamentally change anything in
the statement
so as I said the statement Community
involvement and its the amendments were
subject to consultation
um 12 direct responses were received
um
nine of those responses were from
private individuals one from Essex
County Council one from Chelmsford city
council and one from holbridge residence
Association I would say that some
comments raised concerns or comments
around the spatial options consultation
which was out at the same time so they
weren't always directly corresponding to
the matters that were subject to the sci
consultation
uh so a feedback report has been
prepared which summarizes those main
comments and also appended at appendix B
I believe is a version of the updated
SCI that we are asking the committee to
recommend to council be adopted at that
point uh subject to it being adopted
that sci uh subjects those amendments
would then be the council's adopted SCI
and would fundamentally form the basis
of future engagement in the planning
process
thank you
chairman
um page 7.9
um item 2.24
I wonder if the officers can offer some
explanation as to the wording of this
and why we have informal engagement with
Essex County Council and other service
providers in the preparation of the
infrastructure funding Gap assessment
informal to me sounds all rather too
loose
the officers explain that please because
I'm
minded to seek a change on that thanks
thank you councilor Newport uh I'd
suggest that that was probably the
wording suggested by the County Council
but I agree with you that fundamentally
much more than informal engagement with
cancer council is required so I have no
objection to that being amended to
formal if that is considered appropriate
by the committee I think that's
reasonable I think we'd all say yes
please thank you
foreign
touched on the fact that this um uh
report was consultation and consultation
was during the covid period
um
on that basis has covered skewed the
figures at all has officers has there
been a greater response or a less of a
response because of Kobe how do officers
interpret that
so so if I may I mean this perhaps
talking to the previous item slightly as
well as this one I mean from from
office's perspective I would say the
response rates are both well so
particularly to the spatial options
consultation was very good
there's always an issue I think you know
I would always say in terms of
converting public interest into formal
responses in the planning process
however we did receive over responses
from over 1 500 interested people
which is a I think a three-fold increase
from the previous round of consultation
partly that's because we're starting to
talk about things in more detail so
obviously it's going to get that
slightly more detailed response in terms
of covid I think we obviously held
outdoor public events I'd say in the
main they were they were very well
attended some were
um you know exceptionally well attended
to the point where I think you know it
was challenging to manage I think In
fairness
um and so in that sense I certainly
don't think that covid had particularly
material impact in terms of lessening
public interest in terms of being
accessible it's always difficult if
people
perhaps felt less inclined to go and
view the documents in public it's all
it's always going to be going to be
challenging in that respect however I
think the fact that we held the
consultation when we did I think it was
you know much better than it could have
been at other times in in the pandemic
and certainly we tried through obviously
a consultation strategy that was agreed
by the committee at the time we tried
our best to make sure public awareness
and public engagement was as good as it
could be and the figures don't suggest
to me that we've struggled in that
respect to get a response
so you'd say that it was a positive
effect
the consultations as a whole were
effective in terms of getting public
responses whether or not covid had much
of a positive impact on that I'm not
sure
thanks and chairman
yeah I'm just picking up on what uh
councilor Steptoe said he raises a good
point about um during the pandemic and I
think that
I was just trying to look through here
did we measure the demographic of our
responses to the consultation because I
think as we're all quite well aware it's
a lot of our
um older residents were hiding away and
they would be severely impacted by the
digital divide and I think that's
something that we should be very mindful
of
um
and so I'd just like to know whether or
not we did measure demographics on who
were responding to
thank you councilor Newport I think in
certain ways yes we did we'd probably
have a fairly good locational
understanding of where the responses
came from I think what's challenging is
there's no mechanism really in in the
process to collect people's age at the
point of them making a submission and so
in that sense it's quite difficult to
understand
in terms of
raw numbers exactly how old those
individuals were
and I don't think and you know I'm
saying this
without you know knowing for sure but
I'm not sure
we
would have been able to come up with an
effective way of capturing that
information what I would say I'd
appreciate it's not as good as a as a
you know a data driven understanding is
that I think we have a very good
understanding from the events and from
you know the phone calls and the
correspondence and those more passive
things that obviously went on during the
consultation about the types of and the
demographics of people who engage and I
think what I would say is I'd say
it was probably majority
older people or at least compared to
younger people so in that sense I would
say
although there probably was some kind of
impact on
on those older people in terms of
Engagement I'm not sure
it materially changed the percentage
that we're responding on in that sense
Daniel when you say old are you saying
over 50 of me
I like it well no I mean it's quite
generalized your response to that and
I'd like to know how many people phoned
up to you know because we must do better
we must in future consultations we must
hone
the the input we get from residents is
really important so we do need to be
data driven in where we're putting our
resources as a council it's really
important that we engage with those that
you know that are taking part and we
know where to look because you know at
the moment we're just going
putting it all out there not really sure
you know where we're going with our
efforts
so I think it's something that we should
really focus in on I think that's
something we need to look at for the
future understand that I think Daniel
handles answered the question that came
to him that's fine thank you we've got
two recommendations on the table the
first one is to note the second one is
to make a to take a vote on an amended
version to include the formal engagement
with Essex so on the first one
right there are two recommendations on
the table one is to note and the other
one is to vote upon the second one the
vote upon one will be adjusted slightly
to recognize the formal engagement with
Essex rather than the informal
engagement so the first one is to note
the contents of the statement the
community involvement feedback report
and appendix a is this noted
foreign
noted
number two to recommend to council that
the revised statement of community
involvement at appendix B be adopted
with the amendment to include formal
engagement with Essex rather than
informal
all in favor
unanimous thank you
Jen right to mate local plan transport
assessment high level options paper
Daniel Goodman will present the
officer's report
thank you chairman
as members will understand so the
council is currently in the process of
preparing a new local plan for the
district one of the key pieces of
evidence to inform that new local plan
will be a transport assessment
so clearly the purpose of a transport
assessment is to understand how the how
the highway Network and how the public
transport network is currently
performing to understand the impacts
that development scenarios that could
happen as part of the local plan will
have on those networks and therefore to
identify the mitigation that might be
needed to make that sustainable
So
currently the council has prepared some
initial transport evidence this was
essentially incorporated into the site
appraisal paper that was presented to
the planning policy committee last year
and it looked at every site that had
been put forward to the council uh as
part of the call for sites in in terms
of some high-level transport indicators
I think what we would suggest at this
stage is that level of assessment was
useful but it's not proportionate it's
not uh sorry it's not detailed or
technical enough in order to be able to
inform future work on the local plan uh
one of the reasons for that for example
is that proximity of a site to the
highway network isn't a perfect
indicator of the impact that site would
have on the highway Network
so there is now a need to proceed to a
more technical phase of assessment this
would include a model-based assessment
so the purpose of a model clearly is to
have a pre-prepared or to prepare a uh
essentially a computer computer program
that looks at how much traffic is
already on the network look at Junctions
and look at wait times at Junctions and
to be able to consider how the
population growth that would occur as a
result of building more houses or
building commercial facilities would
have on those traffic flows Junction
waiting times Etc and then to be able to
consider what would happen if mitigation
was put in place such as you know for
example a new roundabout or a new Link
Road
so this paper has been prepared to
present high level options for delivery
of that transport assessment the meeting
the council's executive on the 13th of
July this year the council the executive
sorry requested that the following
positive committee be asked to consider
options for this transport assessment on
a consultative basis
uh two main options for the progression
of that work have been identified these
are in summary to work with Essex County
Council to commission Jacobs to prepare
the further face of work option b to
Tender for a third party consultant to
prepare the further stage of work
uh what I would say at this stage is
that the principle of Eve approach is
sound love most uh every other local
Authority in the county will have
prepared a transport assessment under
one of those two options what I would
just stress at this stage is that
under either option there is an
imperative to work with the County
Council as the highway and
Transportation Authority for the
district it is fundamental to the local
plan being found sound that that County
Council are in support of that work
that's not to say that the council can't
make representation to the County
Council around their input doesn't mean
that the count you know the council
can't hold the County Council to account
around that work but there is a need to
work with the County Council under
either approach
so the report sets out
um some considerations under either of
those two options
I will just quickly summarize those
considerations and I'm happy to expand
upon them uh as part of questions
so
um in terms of cost considerations
um the perhaps the advantage of of
option A is that a model already exists
that's operated by the County Council as
part of their contract with Jacobs I
would just stress as well that Jacobs is
a separate entity to Essex highways and
ringway Jacobs it is it is part of the
same company but it is ultimately a
separate entity
uh so the advantage of that model
already existing in terms of costs means
that the uh the council would
essentially be paying for the modeling
as part of that model and also then the
reporting under option b there are
guaranteed to be higher costs because
what the council would have to do under
that option is to go and create a new
model entirely so that would require
data to be collected to be validated and
then for that model to be put together
um
so testimonies from other councils
appreciating there are some commercial
sensitivities around this but we are
confident in what what the liaison that
we've had is that that extra exercise
under option b would cost at least
another fifty thousand pounds and take
at least another three months that would
obviously account for that data to be
collected and that model to be put
together before any modeling exercise is
done as I say perhaps the option the
advantage under option A is that the
model is already available and therefore
can be used essentially
um fairly quickly
um so I won't talk too much about
timetable considerations because I think
I've probably touched upon upon that
there
um the only other thing perhaps under
timetable considerations that I would
stress is that under either option is
going to need to be an exercise where
this is cancer Council review the
assessment that takes place the
advantage again perhaps under option A
is that because they are
um they already have a contract with
Jacobs it means that ultimately there is
less need for multiple Consultants
having to review that work there perhaps
would be quite a lot of duplication
under option b because you would have
not only the modeling but also the data
collection and and the reporting being
checked by not only the consultant
preparing it but then also SS cancer
Council and Jacobs as part of that
process
so in terms of practical considerations
um
as I said earlier the council would need
to work with Essex County Council on the
Riva option and either option can
deliver the work the council requires
subject to some of these
um some of these costs and timetable
considerations uh similarly in terms of
methodology there's no likely unlike to
be any material difference between these
methodologies and that's because largely
the methodology is prescribed in the
planning practice guidance and there
isn't much room for deviation under
those under those options
uh so what we're asking the committee at
this time is to subject to obviously the
discussion uh that we that we may have
is to indicate a preference for option A
or B to inform a future report to the
executive to take the work forward
thank you
yeah thank you chairman I'll be as brief
as possible I would favor option b I'll
just set up the rationale for that I
think there's a
um firstly I think there's deep
skepticism among residents around Jacobs
about ringway Jacobs Jacobs and Essex
highways to provide good modeling it
might be good modeling but there's a big
skepticism out there and it's not just
amongst residents among a number of
councilors as well and I think
if we use option b
when it tells residents we're listening
to them we understand that they have
skepticism about the modeling produce it
might be the same modeling but it shows
that we're listening and I think that's
very important
um
well actually I think that's the main
point really I'll leave it there so
chairman just can I just clarify what
the officer said when you quoted a
figure for option b was it 50 or 15 000.
so 50 000 above
um above the other options
okay thank you thank you chairman I if I
could just comment uh personally I must
admit I would go with option b
um I think it needs a Fresh Approach to
a traffic assessment within the uh the
area having worked with
um various other parties
um I have a certain amount of skepticism
as has already been mentioned uh with
with ringway Jacobs
um so speaking personally uh I would go
with option b
the question
thank you chairman
um yeah I'm going to take on board what
a
portfolio holder for planning as said
previously that we need to have a good
quality evidence
um so I'm gonna go with option b because
I believe that there is
I think is proven that the evidence that
we've had previously has failed us so I
really think we've got no other
alternative
so that's what I will be supporting
Council of London
just for the second invite Council Ward
the portfolio holder to add comment
please very much indeed uh chairman uh
my obvious concerns will be on resource
implications and I hope that they are
going to be taken on board fully by this
Council that any extra needs will be
granted you know going forward as we
need them because obviously we're going
down a road that we haven't gone down
before and we don't we're given a rough
idea that it's it's 50 Grand more but I
suspect it will possibly be more than
that I don't know but my guess is that
it possibly might be more and our budget
constraints of what they are but if the
members are happy for that to go through
I trust that they will be supporting any
resource requirements that are needed in
the future in regards to this local plan
thank you thank you
Council Newport thank you chairman if I
may just quickly come back on what
council Ward said
I I would
on the um 50 000 pounds possibly more
well I think that will really come down
to whether the council procures a decent
contract and that's what they need to
make sure happens so that those figures
are capped
and the contract negotiated is not such
as such that the cost will spiral out of
control thank you I assume that if we go
down that route it will go through
proper due diligent procurement
okay I'll take a vote all those in favor
of option A
favor of option b
that's five in favor B one in favor of a
thank you
gender item nine new local plan progress
update 2022
Daniel Goodman will present the
officer's report
thank you chairman
so members this report is uh uh well a
summary I suppose of uh the progress of
work under being undertaken on the new
local plan uh some of it is admittedly
um more of a recap but some of it also
is providing an update
so in terms of the new local plan as
members will know we went out to
consultation last summer that was the
spatial options stage and we prepare
presented the feedback report to that
this evening so since the conclusion of
that stage this strategic planning team
have obviously considered the comments
are received and prepared that report
and we have also progressed further work
on the evidence base so the next formal
stage in the preparation of the local
plan is what we're expecting to be a
preferred options stage so preferred
option stage as the name suggests is
where the council would indicate what it
thinks should be done in terms of the
local plan it's not quite the submission
stage where perhaps the council is
saying what will be done but it is
essentially the the point at which the
council begins to indicate a firm
preference for some options over others
so that will be at every scale from
sites and developments strategies all
the way down to you know really detailed
development management policies that are
consider when planning locations come in
so in terms of the time scales for that
consultation admittedly it's probably a
little bit unclear and I think in terms
of the transport assessment work I think
we'll have to take a stock of that
process I'd I'd suggest it will probably
take
um a few weeks if not more to procure
that assessment and obviously then a few
weeks if not more to get that assessment
going however I would say that the
preferred option stage at this time we
are looking probably at summer 2023 for
that um to allow for all that evidence
to take place but clearly the purpose of
the committee
and the you know the purpose of our
reports into the committee will be to
give firmer updates on that
and if we can bring things forward
sooner then obviously we will do that
um I think what's really important is
the preferred option stage needs to be
informed excuse me
needs to be informed by a robust
strategy and site selection process
so when the local plan is examined by
the government the council will be
expected to demonstrate that this
strategy is appropriate so that relates
to scale and location so clearly that it
you know the amount of development
that's being planned for is the right
amount and that it's being put in the in
the right locations
what we're expecting to do is bring
forward a framework for working towards
that strategy and site selection process
so it's unlikely that the next meeting
will bring something forward that looks
to set that strategy process because
clearly that's not appropriate until we
have the evidence in place however I
think what we can begin to do is talk
about the general principles that should
underpin that process so that then we
can start to move forward and take that
evidence on board as it's um as it comes
to the planet policy committee and then
obviously at the end of that process
there will be a decision to be made or
to be recommended around what is done as
I say I mean that that will will be into
next year now but we will do our best to
obviously keep the committee informed
so I won't go back over necessarily the
the spatial options consultation but
clearly there are some long-term options
that the council will need to think
about in its new local plan so
um that includes how we develop more
complete communities so how we plug gaps
in infrastructure what the role is in
the in development in terms of plugging
those holes
how best to move towards net zero and
and other climate change goals at the
earliest opportunity we have a little
bit of a void in in terms of government
policy in terms of when those kinds of
targets might come in but clearly lots
of councils at this stage are looking to
be as ambitious as they can be in that
regard and move forward to
um to Net Zero standards as early as
possible
so prioritizing Brownfield Park
Brownfield contaminated land in sight
selection as a preference over greenford
sites I think that we've spoken about
that many times but also protecting the
district's agricultural Heritage moving
towards local self-sufficiency so uh
something that
um
Dan cuddler mentioned in uh item I'm
going to say six
um was around looking uh resident
priority around
safeguarding agriculture for the future
so in terms of the evidence base a lot
of evidence has been completed much of
that has come to this committee over
many years to be noted and obviously
that evidence base will continue to be
noted or tended to be presented to this
committee most pertinently we are
refreshing our needs evidence so that's
the evidence that looks at perhaps how
much development we might require so
there are updates on going around
housing needs I would just stress that's
not to do with necessarily how much
housing overall is required it's more to
do with how much affordable housing home
housing for older people housing for
people with disabilities is required
obviously the national as we've touched
upon the the overall housing figure is
set nationally and we're not quite sure
how that might change at this stage but
the consultant's working on that
assessment are very cognizant of of what
that movement looks like and they're
highly prepared and likely to have to
prepare obviously addendums to that
report in the future if things do change
uh so we're also looking at Economic
Development needs assessment updates
retail needs assessment updates and
Gypsy and travel accommodation
assessment updates so those Studies have
all been done in the past but we are
looking to prepare newer updates that
look at our needs over a longer period
given many of those reports are now four
or five years old and obviously certain
things have changed
so those assessments are well Advanced
so we're looking to have them hopefully
finished by the end of next month
um and then they will come to the
planning policy committee to be
considered
[Music]
um
uh and I suppose at that stage they will
form a bit of a package I suppose of
needs assessments that will interrelate
to one another
in terms of other evidence
um obviously we have spoken about the
transport assessment uh the other really
important evidence that we're working on
at the moment is a viability assessment
for the local plan so that essentially
will look at the overall cost
implications for the policies in the
local plan and make sure that ultimately
the strategy is viable because that will
be one of the key tests that examination
is that although we might want to that
we're not creating cost implications on
sites that are such that it means that
actually they they aren't capable of
coming forward
um and so there is obviously a balance
to be struck about pushing uh the
infrastructure and development as far as
we can uh without
um it being able to be challenged
Examination for being unviable and then
potentially pressure on us to
um loosen our policies
an infrastructure delivery plan
um ultimately that goes hand in hand
with the local plan and that will look
at the infrastructure that's needed to
make the local plan and its development
sites sustainable so it will cost that
infrastructure and set out when it's
expected to be delivered and by who that
will also support kind of funding bids
if there's any funding Gap and also a
level two strategic flood risk
assessment that we'll look at the flood
risks of specific sites that could be
identified for development so all that
evidence is going to be procured soon
but we are obviously going to have to
take account of the local plan timetable
to make sure that actually that lines up
from From perspective because a lot of
that does depend on knowing uh the
direction of travel shall we say for the
preferred option for that to be tested
essentially
um so the street Appliance team are
continuing to support the preparation of
a non-state planning framework for South
Essex
um so this has evolved over time
originally it was expected to be a
statutory plan but it is now more of a
framework
um so this may set overarching
principles for how the sub-region would
grow and develop and address key press
boundary issues however I think
importantly it will not replace local
plans and it will not um shall we say
slow or otherwise bind those local plans
in terms of its content but it is being
developed with kind of added value in
mind
drawing the drawing the lines between
individual local plans so that that case
for added value can be made
in terms of wider work streams we've
spoken about the statement Community
involvement today
the annual monitoring report for last
monitoring period I'm aware that it says
2022 2023 I will correct that to say
it's 2021-2022.
um that's being prepared currently and I
expect that will be finished in the next
two weeks similarly a brownford register
is in the process of being updated and I
expect again that will be finished in
the next week or so traditionally those
reports have gone out as portfolio
holder decisions
um and I expect that will be how we look
to issue them again but I'm more than
happy to discuss those items
um
if members are interested
so that's a summary of the update I
appreciate it's a little bit of
uncertainty in there but I think as
we've mentioned at previous committees
what we'd like to do is continue to
provide those updates to a little bit of
a standing item and then we can try our
best to keep members informed of
progress on different matters thank you
thank you Daniel
um Council Ward wanted to say something
please first so thank you very much
chairman
together with this bearing in mind that
we want this update on the Brownfield
register which is really really
important
um
I think it's important again looking
back on what has gone previously in this
meeting to make sure that items five and
six I know we're doing the Brownfield
report and everything else they come
back to council as soon as possible come
back to this committee so that we can
look after the look at the various
amendments that have been asked in the
questions answered in regards to members
needs and so they can be satisfied the
whole way through I think that's
important you know that we crack on and
get that on the go thank you
thank you councilor ward council Steptoe
yes thank you chairman
um one or two questions and
clarifications if I may um chairman uh
with regards to item
3.12 on page 9.4 the Gypsy and travelers
accommodation
um there is in undercut under the
current plan of a site that was set
aside at michelin's Farm which I think
is unlikely to be coming forward is
there any mileage in regularizing the
site up in roarth which is currently
technically under an enforcement action
and does the assessment take into
account the odd sites that are dotted
around the district
um sort of pepper potted across the
district that's my first question
um second point I wanted to raise I
don't see anywhere in the report with
regards to duty to cooperate
um where is where are we with that
situation and Castle Ward touched on the
Brownfield register I assume officers
will be sending a copy out of that to to
members here in the council in general
as soon as that is available because it
does say here August September
um you're on a tight deadline now
I think
Mr Goodman's made clear the Brownfield
register will be distributed
thank you chairman thank you councilor
step two uh I think with regards to that
Gypsy and travel accommodation
assessment what I would say firstly is
that's an assessment of demand I suppose
for Gypsy in traveler sites and the way
that demand is generated is from
pitches that already exist that have not
got planning permission and that's you
know small sites with one pitch on all
the way up to you know the the site on
the a1245 so those make up the bulk of
that unmet need and obviously every time
a pitch gets planning permission you
know that comes off of that need if you
like because that needs then met there
are also other assumptions in there
around children growing up and requiring
their own pitch Etc so that the
assessment is very much a kind of
comprehensive picture of the need for
pitches what it won't address is the
supply of those pitches other than to
say this is what has planning permission
and therefore this is what does not
generate a new need I think in terms of
decisions to regularize other sites I
think that's probably not actually
planning policy
in a sense I think that's probably more
you know a council decision and that
would come via development management
really the only way that would probably
come via the local plan is obviously if
we said in the local plan which we could
that our policy is is that those sites
could achieve planning permission and
therefore we allow for allow for that in
the policy I think at this time
if if you know those households are
entitled to make a planning application
if they want to but that would be for
development committee to decide and I
don't think
probably there's anything in the Gypsy
travel accommodation assessment that
would address the suitability of those
sites outside of a planning application
process so I think there are probably
slightly different processes as part of
this
but if we still have an unmet need issue
in a year two years time that the local
plan can address and obviously
um you know there will be options for
doing that I just think on
a short-term basis it's probably more of
a development management process than a
planning policy process
oh yes sorry so uh yeah so I I mean the
feedback report for the spatial options
consultation set out the kind of the
responses from duty to cooperate
Partners
um and I think you know in terms of an
update I mean there isn't
um there isn't particularly an update
because
other than to say I suppose with respect
to Castle Point Council Ambassador and
councils both councils have made
decisions to pause work on their local
plans and so in those sense that
relationship is slightly different now
because clearly those local plans that
they had that we agreed
statement of Common Grounds we've no
longer exist in a sense so in that sense
that relationship needs to kind of be
changed but until they prepare start
preparing work on their local plans that
work hasn't really commenced in terms of
um with Southend Council I mean they as
I understand it are working on their
local plan they're looking at their
strategy options as are we we identify
in the spatial options consultation
obviously that strategy that had a bit
of synergy but there's no you know
nothing advanced in terms of you know
that discussion or nothing advanced in
terms of the strategy and site selection
process and obviously as I think as I've
said out in the report that remains
within our local plans gift to resolve
so in that sense there probably isn't an
update and that's why I have I've
admitted to give one really
the only exception to that I will take
this opportunity to say is that we have
had a formal request from message scans
Council to a career statement statement
of common ground with them at this stage
so you know I expect we will present
um the draft wording of that to be
agreed in due course
um so that is perhaps the exception but
on the other relationships I'd say
there's probably not a concrete update
to give I'm afraid
he also come to this committee
historically probably wouldn't come to
this committee it would go out as a
portfolio hold a decision I would
suggest but I have no problem with
you know it it being shared once kind of
in in that domain I have no problem with
but historically we would do it via the
portfolio holder decision route because
it tends to be bigger than the bigger
than the local plan it tends to be kind
of slightly
I don't know more I don't know more
strategic planning than the local plan
core but
um I mean I'm happy to discuss that yeah
I'd personally prefer it to come to this
committee and so we could discuss it I
think that would be a good option
chairman with regards to council
steptoe's suggestion it's something we
would need to look at um uh it might
just be a portfolio or decision but
uh Mr Goodman probably could bring it
back as an update for um for for
um some observations by committee
members okay thank you
Council board
thank you very much chairman uh just to
remind members that we do have a site
which is in michelins and we are
currently looking at uh
CPO on that site so this is something we
are currently looking at and
investigating whether we can go forward
with that area
thank you thank you councilor Newport
you had a question
thank you chairman yes uh I'd like to
pick up on the Gypsy and traveler
accommodation assessment it's one of my
favorite subjects because
it's been ongoing for
well as long as I can remember and
I just want to pick up on a point that
councilor Steptoe made about
um whether those all those temporary
sites that the council keeps granting
our um
whose decision would it be whether they
were legalized or become our policy is
that not a planning policy decision or
is that where would that fall to
and
where is this definitive list of all
these different sites because I can't
get my hands on it for love nor money
and I think it's important we actually
know what we're dealing with and I think
that that needs to come to the to the
committee as part of this evidence that
we're looking at thank you
thank you councilor Newport I think in
terms of
um the components of need and the demand
I mean I suppose what I would say is
that in terms of how the local plan
might address it and therefore how it
might come to planning policy committee
is clearly if we have an unmet need
for example when we're looking at the
preferred option stage so we will report
the GTAA update into this committee
first and foremost but if we have an
unmet need at that stage then obviously
the options that might be before the
committee are to include something in
the local plan around a policy that I
suppose makes it easier for those
existing sites to become regularized or
it might be to identify new land for
Egyptian traveler site or it might be to
do something something else I suppose in
the short term
I suppose there's there's not much that
the local plan can do to regularize
those sites because what they need to be
regularized is planning permission
really so what those landowners could do
is obviously choose to make a planning
application then it's up for development
committee to decide if they want to
Grant it or not so there's nothing you
know really that I can think of as part
of this process that would provide an
accelerated solution for that
you know in theory anybody can make
planning planning application for
anything but I suppose
the difficulty that those sites clearly
have is is the balance between you know
typically green belt and and the need
and so I wouldn't want to kind of
pre-judge any decision development
committee might choose to make or not
make in the future but I think it is the
timing issue I I think there's something
can be done in the local plan to address
the issue but it's if there's a desire
by Council or whomever to do something
sooner then I think that probably is
like I say a matter of that would
require planning applications ultimately
that's kind of out I think probably
outside the local plans influence to
kind of bring those planning
applications to reality
members there's one recommendation at
paragraph 9.1 on page 9.7 of the report
which is to note the local plan progress
update
August 2022 a set out in this report
members is this noted
thank you
meeting closed at eight minutes past
nine
thank you